[Musica]
poi a partire da una piccola premessa
che può sembrare fuori contesto
gli speaker che mi mi hanno proceduto
hanno parlato principalmente di valori
positivi cose molto belle
l'integrazione umanità eccetera ecco io
non sono un buono non faccio finta di
esserlo
non voglio esserlo e spero che alla fine
di questo talk avrete la risposta al
perché questo talk avviene in un momento
particolare della mia vita in cui si sta
per chiudere un ciclo di cui non posso
parlarvi molto ma che in qualche modo ha
visto coinvolte le persone vicino a me
in determinati avvenimenti perché non mi
conoscesse mi occupo principalmente di
sicurezza informatica sono quello che
diciamo fare comune e serie tv vi hanno
sopra limina soprannominato hager questo
messo anche la divisa col cappuccio
perché è chiaro che uno deve tenere
sempre loro fino alla fine questo sono
io sono io pixel izzato probabilmente sì
sono io psichiatri pixel izzato anche
perché la fotografia e il risultato
diverso ma non vi perdete niente ero
molto più carino di oggi come tutti i
bimbi questo talk è la storia di come
quel bambino e molti bambini come quel
bambino siano in qualche modo diventati
delle armi e come dei processi di come
dei processi di vita possono portare
delle persone us con traffico a volte
cose molto più grandi di loro e che non
avrebbero mai immaginato di farne parte
e come soprattutto il titolo del talk
significa un atomizzazione dell'atomica
ovvero come se passate ad armi di
distruzione di massa
per questo non sono non è un talk carino
il mio a armi di distruzione di massa
responsabili e divise fra più persone
come tutti i bambini anche io ho giocato
alla playstation perso molti di voi la
maglia è fatta apposta qualcuno ha
riconosciuto qualcuno non lo avrà
riconosciuta avevo circa 9 anni quando
iniziato a giocare a questo gioco
qualcuno che quello conosce sicuramente
parlava di spionaggio di spie era tutta
una cosa molto interessante agli occhi
di un bambino era un qualcosa di lontano
in qualche modo che faceva parte di
quello che poteva essere immaginario no
di un film di un di un racconto di altre
diciamo cose negli anni giocando questo
gioco ma poi crescendo mi sono
appassionato a quello che l'informatica
soprattutto la sicurezza informatica e
diciamo la mia curiosità negli anni mi
ha portato a mettere mano a cose a cui
non dovevo mettere mano nè a farmi
notare tra virgolette da persone che
sono incaricate di notare altre persone
curiose diciamo curiosi che cercano
altri curiosi nel tempo la mia curiosità
aumentata fino a circa i miei 19 anni
immagino che molti di voi ha 19 anni
avevano e spero per voi una vita molto
più tranquilla perché quando sei in
mezzo certe cose è tutto molto
affascinante no tutti vogliamo fa
vogliamo avere un grosso segreto da non
raccontare nessuno viverci con un grosso
segreto o viverci sapendo di essere
qualche modo in qualcosa di particolare
non è stato esattamente divertente quel
bambino che giocava a questo gioco e poi
è diventato sempre curioso nel 2012 è
finito su wikileaks con un mandato di
cattura internazionale per spionaggio
chi smanetta di voi può andare su
wikileaks fra nomi pseudonimi cercare
chi sono e che cosa ho fatto parte ma
non è tanto su di me questo talk questo
e per dirvi che come vi ho detto io non
sono in buono le mie azioni direttamente
o indirettamente hanno causato dei danni
persone cose strutture probabilmente
qualcuno c'è c'è pure rimesso qualcosa
di oltre della di un oggetto e non è
facile sempre ha saputo quando sta per
terminare un percorso di vita guardare
indietro e pensare a quello che è
successo come detto questo non è un talk
su di me questa è la giusta una
parentesi per dirvi che ci sono persone
come me le persone soprattutto molto più
dentro di me che in qualche modo
persevera nel male e non per servono nel
male semplicemente perché si divertono a
farlo un po di cenni storici che cos'è
la guerra informatica per guerra
informatico per arma informatica si
intende il software un virus informatico
che utilizzato su una specifica
infrastruttura può causare dei danni a
catena e il suo singolo utilizzo può
disabilitare o un sistema stesso o una
serie di sistemi per arma di distruzione
di massa
uno come le armi nucleari o le armi
batteriologiche si indicano quelle armi
in cui il singolo utilizzo esattamente
come l'arma informatica crea degli
effetti a catena
cenni storici questo un dipinto della
peste nera durante il medioevo spesso e
volentieri fazioni rivali città rivali
diciamo alleanze rivali soprattutto dove
la festa non era arrivata si cercava di
lanciare al di là delle mura nemiche o
fare in qualche modo infiltrare persone
che portavano il morbo per uccidere la
popolazione locale
questo è un primo esempio di distruzioni
di massa si è fatta ancora prima del
medioevo si è fatto già dai tempi dei
romani dei greci ma diciamo nel medioevo
ha avuto una grande espansione è uno dei
motivi per cui la peste nera italiana si
è espansa anche in francia e perché
alcuni infette diciamo persone infettate
dal italia venivano spostate in francia
per essere utilizzate come armi vere e
proprie in cambio di favori economici ai
familiari che sopravvivevano questo
progetto manhattan 1940 inizia
ufficialmente a 40 42
questo è stato forse il progetto di
ricerca più grande e più meglio
finanziato sicuramente diciamo della
storia almeno della storia fino a quel
punto l'idea era molto semplice almeno
semplice in nel dire mettere insieme le
menti più importanti del del tempo
soprattutto scienziati anche di
nazionale di etnie ebraica in italia
abbiamo fermi che ha lavorato al
progetto manhattan per studiare la
fissione nucleare la fusione nucleare
soprattutto la fissione in prima istanza
per capire usi bellici e usi civili di
questa enorme potenza che era stata già
teorizzata ancora prima del progetto
manhattan da davvero che non solo i
tedeschi lavorare gli americani non vedo
su questo parla veramente anche tedeschi
e giapponesi e qualcosa anche italiani
avevano già iniziato a lavorare perché
era già di condominio con
l'esistenza di questa forza di questa
forza esplosiva la progetto manhattan e
6 agosto 1945
abbiamo avuto il primo utilizzo di
un'arma nucleare su una popolazione
civile a nagasaki alle 8 di mattina a
hiroshima alle 8 di mattina circa 60
mila morti
più ce ne saranno quasi lo stesso numero
negli anni successivi a causa
dell'esposizione alla sezione queste
eccolo teatro lei non tutti li conoscono
perché è stato uno dei piloti della crew
del primo bombardamento nel l'enola gay
l'enola gay era un b 29 cioè un aereo da
bombardamento tattico americano
all'interno c'erano più persone non
erano aerei volativa più tagliare una
singola persona
questa persona si è pentita
molto di quello che ho fatto e questo ha
fatto sì che lui stesso si deprimesse ha
scritto dei libri se non è molto belli
ha tentato più volte il suicidio e ha
rifiutato 250.000 dollari di pensione
mensile purché lo stato americano non
utilizzasse la sua figura come figura
eroica e morto nella sostanziale nella
totale dimenticanza di tutto e di tutti
autorizzazione dell'atomica un'arma
nucleare è una in realtà un processo
molto semplice c'è un proiettile di
uranio che viene sparato quello stop
molto semplificando verso un altro verso
un altro muro di uranio e plutonio e
questo genera una reazione a catena fino
all'esplosione
per fare questo
avete bisogno di un importantissimo in
piano industriale che bisogno di acqua
pesante arricchimento dell'uranio
avete bisogno di un clan thing che
effettivamente si vede e non è qualcosa
che diciamo
potete nascondere gli italiani ne sanno
qualcosa insomma iracheni nell'ottanta
iraniani oggi ne sanno qualcosa non è
qualcosa facilmente nascondibile se voi
state facendo ricerche su nucleare
l'uranio è tracciato c'è un'agenzia
internazionale che fa questo non è un
qualcosa che tendenzialmente qualcuno si
sveglia la mattina fa dice oggi che
facciamo possiamo una centrale nucleare
e il richiamo dell'uranio e facciamo una
produzione nucleare non è così questo
crea la grande differenza con la guerra
informatica la guerra informatica è
fatta da singole persone che con singoli
dispositivi possono creare armamenti che
potenzialmente hanno lo stesso effetto
di devastazione di un anno nucleare ma
col beneficio di essere totalmente
anonimi se qualcuno qua dentro
in qualche modo torna a casa e sul suo
computer e un codice sorgente di un
virus di posta xdent questo stuxnet
codice sorgente di stuxnet st stuxnet è
stata la prima arma informatica nota
essere utilizzata sul campo di battaglia
o almeno su elementi tattici con stuxnet
forze armate israeliane disabilitato le
centrali di haruki arricchimento
dell'iran affermando praticamente il
programma ogni anno nucleare per circa
cinque anni con un virus informatico
se qualcuno di voi l'avesse fatto o con
qualcuno di voi stesse lavorando su una
tecnologia simile nessuno ne sapesse
niente perché la il vantaggio di questo
tipo di armi e che mentre da qualche
parte avete bisogno
di questa è la classica immagine della
casa molto semplice molto standard
mentre dall'altra parte avete bisogno di
enormi quantità industriali di
attrezzatura movimentazione eccetera
eccetera
oggi tutto quello che serve buona skill
un accesso a internet e per esempio se
volete come nel caso di stuxnet creare
un virus informatico che funziona su
questo dispositivo e si mandi cast 7
nelle versioni mille e duecento o
trecento questo e dispositivo scada
principalmente che viene utilizzata da
tutti i sistemi energetici occidentali
un virus informatico su larga scala che
target iza quel sistema potrebbe mandare
i black da in shodown per diversi mesi
intere par porzioni di nazioni in
ucraina nel 2014 operativi del gruppo
gru sono servizi segreti russi hanno
attaccato i sistemi delle sistema
energetico ucraino ma andando
praticamente offline tutta la parte est
dell'ucraina
questo lo stesso attacco più sofisticato
certo potrebbe essere condotto anche
l'italia
edwards non è una persona che ha fatto
un mestiere che facevano quelle persone
dall'altra parte ma che a un certo punto
si è tirata indietro perché chi fa
questo mestiere ha capito in fondo di
essere un arma di distruzione umana cioè
di essere qualcuno che è anche non
implementato in una gerarchia militare
strutturata senza movimenti di armi
senza particolari elementi può creare
danni sistemici
ecco edward numeri in questo momento si
occupava di intelligence quindi era più
una operatori estrapolazione
informazione ci sono persone come edward
noren in tutti i paesi del mondo che si
occupano di creare invece armamenti come
quelli che vi ho descritto prima cioè
armamenti che attaccano
sistemi dei sistemi fognari sistemi
elettrici sistemi che posso attaccare ai
porti aeroporti gasdotti oleodotti tutte
infrastrutture critiche che possono
portare anche alla morte di persone
durante il black lo showdown in ucraina
sono morti nell'incubatrice 16 donati
quindi problemi possono essere davvero
molto gravi e si arriva a figata 33 0 1
qualcuno di voi l'ha mai sentito
nominare no si cada 33 0 1 e un
programma segreto di cui nessuno ne sa
niente neanche io che è iniziato a
espandersi su internet con la
pubblicazione di enigmi matematici e
informatici che sono tendenzialmente
risolvibili solo diciamo dal 0,00 per
cento delle persone che hanno questa
potenzialità
chi è entrato il si cada o chi ha avuto
a che fare consigliata con il team
livello di si cada ha capito che in
realtà si kata è un auto organizzazione
o almeno si dice che se non ci sono
conferme riguardo è un auto
organizzazione trasversale cioè
internazionale non gestita da stati di
persone che hanno un potenziale
informatico cosiddetto di distruzione di
massa che hanno iniziato informalmente a
collaborare e lo hanno fatto
iniziando a tirar fuori degli enigmi
informatici di questo tipo che servono
solo a identificare le persone che hanno
particolari diciamo particolari
predisposizioni per risolvere questo
tipo di enigmi fino a oggi ci sono stati
diversi enigmi le persone che fanno
parte di casa non si parlano fra di loro
non si conoscono ed è un'organizzazione
proprio per far fatta per prendere le
varie spie o vari long war lone wolf
controllati da stati autonomi che hanno
queste capacità e portarli un tavolo di
discussione per evitare lo spread ying
di armi di distruzione di massa
e questo perché questo è un altro enigma
edificata
questo perché da quando è nata la
l'organizzazione che parla fra di loro
abbiamo avuto circa 39 morti sospette
età sotto i 40 anni loro operato
non si sa quanto effettivamente vita mi
sono fatto perché spesso e volentieri
dovete sapere che chi persegue il male
lo persegue fa continua propria
coscienza ma lo persegue anche per il
vostro bene
grazie mille
[Musica]